Hello
bitches.
I would love to play you.
The dinosaurs are not real video.
Do it.
God.
See if he flagged JV.
We probably can't play it on youtube where we'll get pulled,
but we can play the Wii,
the audio,
right,
play the audio.
We'll put the video up on the screen and play the audio for you.
And you could just fucking,
your head could turn beet red smokes can come out of your ears.
Because the thing is about these videos,
and this is the issue that I have with not just videos,
but also with blogs.
People,
you're writing things and you're not,
you're not being checked as you're going along.
So it's,
it's just you broadcasting and idea.
It's not a conversation.
And because of that,
you can give off the illusion of expertise without being checked.
Here it goes.
Dinosaurs never existed.
And by my God,
Eric to bay,
this is the,
the flat Earth Guy.
Yeah.
The guy that does 200 proofs,
the earth is flat.
Everybody has debunked.
Fucking,
oh no,
no,
no.
Shills shows or listen to this guy
of the royal society.
Don't you dare mention anyone's name assholes,
natural history department in 1842 or in other words,
the existence of dinosaurs was first speculatively hypothesized by young
knighted museum head.
Coincidentally in the mid 19th century,
during the heyday of evolutionism before a single dinosaur fossil had ever been
found wrong.
They sound pause,
pause every time.
Pause,
uh,
dinosaurs.
Uh,
we,
we discovered marine reptiles and the first dinosaurs about a century before
that.
So that right there,
Eric,
you're fucking wrong.
Wups it's like,
don't bring your flat Earth Bullshit into my profession.
Now I'm pissed.
But keep going.
Yeah,
keep,
keep us rolling
and stream.
Press worldwide.
Got To work hyping stories of these supposedly long lost animals.
And then Lo and behold,
12 years later in 1854,
Ferdinand Vandeveer Hayden,
during his exploration of the upper Missouri River,
found proof of Owen's theory.
A few unidentified teeth he mailed to leading paleontologist Joseph Leidy,
who several years later declared them to be from an ancient extinct track,
a don dinosaur,
which beyond ironic.
So
that's because we can do things like look at modern analogs and see how teeth
are fucking made.
We know if it's a Predator or if its prey,
we know if it's an herbivore or a carnivore,
we know how teeth are fucking built.
Even back then,
even when they're doing naturalistic drawings like this,
it's like,
like the,
the,
the mcgalin on tooth on my arm.
It is a predator.
It's obviously a [inaudible] Galla don or mega.
Dot.
How do you say it?
It depends on your,
you're in fast as can be on a different syllable.
It's both.
It's not like nuclear new Cuellar no,
no cause cause it doesn't have to use,
um,
but it's spelled,
it's spelled the same but it's like dimetrodon or dimetrodon.
Oh,
it's the same thing in the [inaudible] on,
Oh God,
you're God.
Keep doing this.
What is it?
20 minutes.
Firstly,
needless to say that it is impossible to reconstruct an entire hypothetical
ancient animal based on a few teeth.
But even more importantly,
it is dubious that a myriad of tile,
bird and reptile mammal,
transitional forms necessary for the blossoming theory of evolution would be
hypothesized and then conveniently discovered by teams of evolutionist
archeologists purposely out looking to find such fossils.
It is even more dubious that such fossils have supposedly existed for millions
of years,
but we're never found by or known to any civilization in the history of
humanity.
Kill evolution.
Okay.
Yeah.
The reason why we didn't know about things beforehand because we weren't doing
shit like wholesale intellectual studies of science when people were building
fucking pyramids and stuff like that.
That's why we have different ages in,
throughout anthropological records.
We have the brand age and Iron Age and all that because we have to do things
like figure out the land around us.
And when we start finding really old bones like,
hey,
this looks like a really big chicken bone.
What the fuck?
Or this looks like a huge human with a single eye.
We start looking at stuff like that saying just wholesale fucking bullshit like
that.
Goddamn.
Ah,
but that's a,
that's what a youtube videos and youtube conspiracy theory video is.
Oh,
I know.
One person getting to spill.
There's nonsense and w there unchecked.
Yeah.
This is why I wanted to play this for you.
And,
um,
uh,
response videos can be blocked by the original person.
They can curate all comments.
They can only allow certain ones through.
They can moderate everything.
Same with a blog.
Same with all of that.
They control their own criticism.
There's a guy right now that a lot of the Paleo community,
he's going after.
His name's David Peters.
He's a jackass,
um,
who's like doing stupid things like all reptiles or mammals and all of these
claims should be in this and just all this crap.
Um,
he wholesale copied an article from,
a colleague of mine posted it,
which is violation of copyright because he's attempting to supersede that work
by importing his own ideas to it.
He will refuse any critical comments to be posted on his wordpress site.
That's a little,
it's really common now.
Yeah.
It's really common with people.
The war of ideas in the comment section.
That's where it's being fought.
Yeah.
It's because it's an echo chamber.
It's like people don't look as why do people think the world is flat or why do
people think dinosaurs don't exist there?
Google boolean search is dinosaurs don't exist or creationism is true.
Evolution is false.
The earth is flat.
Chem trails exist.
They're creating their own echo chamber and preaching to their own fucking
choir,
and then they have a message board and then go on that message board.
Massive confirmation bias.
Nobody,
anybody that doesn't follow that line gets booted out.
Let's play more of this because it gets,
it gets better.
Journalism's May sonic renaissance in the mid 19th century,
David was and he wrote,
why are there no discoveries by native Americans in all the years previous when
they roamed the American continents because they weren't doing a fucking earth
dinosaurs in the native American religion or tradition because they were all
dead that matter.
Why would there no discoveries prior to the 19th century in any part of the
world there could have gone.
You didn't know what it was.
That's to the world book.
It's like the same thing with mammoth cyclops.
Yeah.
We didn't know what the fuck it was.
We didn't know.
It was a massive,
a massive elephant species.
We thought it was a giant person.
Yeah.
When the first animals were discovered in the liberate tarpits,
uh,
before 1913,
they thought it was livestock that got trapped in there and died.
Then they realized,
holy fuck cows don't have nine inch long incisors that are,
you know,
perfectly evolved to slash open the throats of things.
And then you started questioning.
So the native Americans and all the people they were finding possibly scatters
of bone and didn't know what it was.
Uh,
did the uh,
did the northern uh,
first people start licking bones and rocks?
No,
we,
we discovered that,
you know,
the science as it figures out going,
hey,
this is porous material.
If I lik porous material,
it's going to stick to my tongue.
Holy Fuck,
that's a fossil.
This,
this,
this kind of just,
he,
the problem with you Eric,
is you are starting from an improper position.
You are starting on a confirmation bias.
You are stating from the beginning that dinosaurs don't exist and you were using
pair of Delia and apathy Enia the ability for humans to find patterns in order
to fit your bullshit and then only cherry pick what belongs.
That's,
that's what,
that's what he does with fucking flat earth.
And the problem with this is like I was saying earlier,
because now the stupid minority has a voice.
All,
I dunno how many million people subscribe to his fucking channel.
Every single flat earth dip shit is going to go 61,000 people.
Okay,
look at that 300,000 views and here's the thing.
Check out the comments.
The comments he calms down are almost identical.
Look,
34 86 to 34 94 are you kidding me?
Son of a bitch.
Oh,
but I remember being forced to have the same dinosaur toys.
Is Everyone Matt?
Yeah,
that's because it's called consumerism.
Flat Earth.
No dinosaur.
What's the point in making these?
Okay.
See,
good.
Good for you.
Go in there.
Extremely great research.
Love this very much.
Thank you Max Haskins.
Don't breed.
Don't ruin dinosaurs with facts.
Fuck you.
And there's more.
My favorite animal.
Here's another problem.
His voice is annoying as fuck.
Oh my God,
let's play more.
Oh thanks.
Good luck to you.
Before the 18 hundreds no one ever knew that dinosaurs existed during the late
18 hundreds early 19 hundreds large deposits of dinosaur remains were
discovered.
Why has man suddenly made all these discoveries?
No tribes,
cultures or countries in the world ever discovered a dinosaur bone before the
mid 18 hundreds and then they were suddenly found all over the world in North
America,
South America,
Europe,
Asia,
Africa,
Argentina,
Belgium,
Mongolia,
Tanzania,
West Germany and many other places apparently had larger deposits of dinosaur
fossils.
Never before seen.
Well because we find the first one and then we're like,
Holy Shit,
there must be more of these out there.
And then the bone more started between Ogden and marsh.
You had the man tell collection with the first Iguanas,
Don that was found and they put it and they made these really stupid statues and
put them in Crystal Palace in London.
And uh,
Mary Anning,
one of the first theme will be first female pal paleontologist.
And one of the first people actually find fossils.
She discovered the [inaudible] Mary Anning was the girl from the rhyme.
She sells seashells on the seashore cause that's what she did as a child.
And as she was looking for seashells,
she found a skeleton of an atheist sore buried and a cliff.
Oh yeah.
As like a kid.
I think she was 12,
13 of Holy Shit.
I think paleontology,
Twitter is going to rip me apart for not knowing the thing,
but come on,
I'm,
I'm hyped up now.
I'm drunk.
He's hyped up.
I'm not dude,
that's one beer.
All right.
I've got it.
Had before you got here.
None.
We got excited.
I've got nine more in there.
Um,
I'm going to need them.
Uh,
yeah,
it's just so Marianne and discovered a [inaudible] and once you discover
something like that,
you want to go around the world and say,
Hey,
where else is this stuff?
Let's go somewhere that no one has been,
which means North America,
South America,
Tanzania believes all the things that Captain Jack Ass just rattled off.
Captain Fuckface.
So Tom kept kept my face.
God fucking fuck.
What did shit given?
I don't know.
Just something.
Yeah,
I stole.
I stole shit given from a Trump thing,
but Gibbons shit given like a monkey,
like a gibbon monkey ape.
I think they're technically apes.
Gibbons are eight.
I think Gibbons are raped.
Hmm.
They have tails.
No Art.
All Apes.
Monkeys.
But not all monkeys or apes.
No.
Apes and monkeys are prime.
But a monkey is just,
it's not a technical term.
Right?
It's not a scientific term.
There was an article that was written there was explaining that all apes or
monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
See if you can find that.
Well,
we'll go to that afterwards probably because like one of those beers.
Okay,
let's,
let's keep this rolling.
I don't want to,
I want to see how deep we can go with this bake character.
I don't know what kind of explored for thousands for this time.
No one ever found a dinosaur fossil before.
According to the book,
the dinosaur project,
paleontological journalists,
Wayne Grady,
cause the period following this from around 1870 to 1880 became a period in
North America where some of the most underhanded shenanigans in the history of
science were conducted.
That's because of the two paleontologists going at it against each other going,
I can find the cooler thing.
No,
I'm going to find more shit than you.
It was called the bone wars.
Ogden versus marsh.
You already talked about this,
right?
Yeah.
What was,
what was underhanded about it?
They would,
uh,
they would,
um,
sabotage each other's digs.
They would try and steal fossils.
They were assholes.
But because of the competition,
it's like a fight when you have one dude that,
you know,
two dudes had been training all their lives and trying to do the whole thing.
The more amped up one gets,
the more amped up the others gate.
It's going to be a fucking,
just throw down.
This is what happened on an intellectual and fieldwork scale.
You had two guys trying to make a name for themselves in a burgeoning brand new
field that just wanted to get in and roll and they had direct competition with
each other.
So it's going to be,
you know,
fuck you.
I'm going to find these bones first.
And it,
it got nasty man.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's like,
think of it as Edison versus Tesla's paleontology,
right?
Except Tesla wasn't very aggressive.
He sort of like let all that shit
true.
True,
very true.
Keep keep this going on as the great dinosaur rash or the bone wars.
Edward Drinker Co of the academy off of the Peabody Museum of natural history
began a lifelong rivalry and passion for a dinosaur hunting.
I said on my bad,
but became bitter enemies during the legendary feud involving double crossing
slander,
bribery,
theft,
spying and destruction of bones by both parties.
Marsh is said to have discovered over 500 different ancient species including 80
dinosaurs while cope discovered 56 out of the hundred and 36 dinosaur species
supposedly discovered by the two men.
However,
close with 32 are presently considered valid as the rest of all proven to be
falsifications and fabrications.
Bullshit Bull Shit,
not a falsifications or fabrication.
Turns out a lot of those dinosaurs.
We're the same species that were previously discovered,
so oh look,
this sauropod femur looks a lot like that.
Sauropod Femur,
but I found this slightly in a different place,
so I'm going to name it a new species.
Nope.
Turns out those are both Brontosaurus or a pat disorders or triceratops or
stegosaurs,
anything like that.
Um,
that,
that is just an outright fucking lie that he just said.
When things are discovered,
it turns out that they're the same.
It becomes taxonomically what's called a junior synonym.
So,
uh,
for example,
tyrannosaurus rex had another name for a really long time.
It's totally mega,
mega,
no one,
regardless,
whatever the first name for it was,
was technically the first discovered name for it.
But since tyrannosaurus rex became the more popular,
the more documented,
the more thing that became a junior synonym or what,
or in that one actually became what we call no mum obscure him.
There were the obscure name no longer,
uh,
no longer talked about.
But that's what happened.
It wasn't an outright fabrication.
It was two dudes finding bones of the same species or type of animal,
but not naming it the same thing.
So that's,
that's an absolute bullshit.
Eric Dubay outright lie
of them once claimed to find a complete skeleton either.
So all their work involved reconstructions,
in fact,
to this day,
no complete skeleton has ever been found.
And so all dinosaurs are reconstruction.
Well,
Shit.
Uh,
Su in the field museum is,
well,
not a hundred percent complete,
98% complete,
including formerly unknown elements from any other train.
Assor.
Um,
I believe,
uh,
a commercial paleontology group just found like a 99% or almost all 100%
complete dinosaur.
We have found entireties or near entireties of animals.
So He's right by a very small technicality of one or 2%.
Exactly.
But what he's implying is completely misleading.
He's implying that they're finding a shin bone and drawing and a dinosaur
around.
Exactly.
But no,
like we,
we'll find,
we can find 70% of a train.
This horse wrecks.
We know what they look like.
So yeah,
we will use three d printing or casting of all that many.
And Yeah,
I'm happily admitting this because everyone knows,
or at least everyone should know,
many dinosaurs in museums are what we call conglomerates.
It will be,
uh,
see a triceratops.
The skull will be real.
Maybe the front half of the animals,
some ribs,
maybe some tail vertebrae or the pelvis will be from one animal.
We will have to use casts of other triceratops that we have throughout
paleontology in other museums.
Many of the fossils you see on display,
our casts now cast doesn't mean bullshit created on the spot.
It means very technically,
this is a cast that is a replica of an actual existing bone that was wrapped,
made a mold of,
and then filled with resin,
painted to the correct color.
It is the exact match of a bone that exists.
It is not something we are just making up.
That is bullshit and I hate that when they come in and go,
oh look,
that's link plastic.
Yeah,
it's plants and it gets all like,
well,
yeah,
you know why fossils are fucking fragile.
It takes us weeks to get a single bone out and then it is covered in glue.
It is wrapped in tissue paper.
Sometimes tin foil,
a shit ton of plaster and reinforcement is wrapped around it.
Then it has to be very carefully slid down a mountain on a car hood in one time
or airlifted out in another and put in the back of trucks and then take an all
the way to its museum and then cracked open and then PR and then prepared
everything has to get,
uh,
get lift off it very carefully and we're adding more glue as we're going because
if you sneeze wrong on some,
uh,
on some,
mineralized specimens,
it goes away.
It just goes boom.
So you have to work very carefully in a booth with like an error Brater so
you're just,
you're shooting extremely fine particles just to get the top millimeter of
material off.
This is hard detailed work on things that are 65 plus million years old that if
we're not careful,
they fall apart.
We are not going to wrap something like that in fucking steal and put it up on a
mount,
especially somewhere,
I dunno like Los Angeles where things like earthquakes happen.
It's statements like that that he makes are just fucking irritating.
Keep it,
keep it going.
The last thing he wrote,
discoveries and excavations.
The same not to be made by disinterested people such as farmers,
ranchers,
hikers,
bullshit,
bullshit.
Building constructional issues they face is a fucking lutely bullshit.
Fuck you Eric.
I'm a Paleo Monitor.
You asshole.
I am actually contracted to go out to fucking building sites and make sure
fossils are protected and dug up correctly.
In fact,
you know what Jack Ass,
I found a whale in downtown La.
Fuck you Eric.
Do Bay.
He found a whale.
I found a way only downtown away.
Oh,
you talked about this last podcast you were talking about how to,
they had a shutdown construction.
Exactly.
You know why?
Cause building construction finds fucking dinosaurs and Ma and whales and pre
stork animals.
You Jack Ass.
Ah,
fuck.
Fuck you farmers.
So,
uh,
sue was found on a guy's farm.
There have been numerous dinosaurs,
numerous prehistoric animals found on a guy's farm.
By the way,
there's an entire private area up in Bakersfield called shark's tooth hill where
they find meg teeth.
Miguel on onto all the fucking time.
It's honors field in Bakersfield.
It's on private land farmers builders.
Recreational people.
Yeah.
Hey,
guess what?
A couple people hiking in Red Rock Canyon up near Palmdale found a trackway from
an ancient camel rec.
We recreational people.
Yeah.
This happens all the fucking time.
The reason why it's happening more and more lately it's because people know what
they're looking for now.
They understand.
Wow,
there could be shit out here.
Hey,
if we're digging a road,
if we're widening the 99 freeway in Fresno,
Holy Shit,
we hit a mammoth or holy shit,
we found a whale in downtown la like with within blocks of the one 10 freeway
and good Samaritan Hospital.
I won't tell you where I can't,
but yeah,
I just wanted to secrecy.
Yeah.
It's just part of the part of the contracts that's,
that's the deal.
Because if you find something,
if you find something there,
you can find more shit.
We found over 400 specimens of shark teeth whale's,
uh,
or a rib cage of a whale,
snails,
fossil coral,
all of this because downtown La was underwater 7 million years ago and yeah,
that's,
Oh my God,
that's fucking bullshit.
Ah,
keep going.
Yeah.
Blind trench digger and mining industry personnel found all the time by people
with a vested interest such as paleontologists scientists,
university professors,
and museum organization personnel who meaning trained motherfuckers,
dinosaur bones,
or who have studied dinosaurs previously.
Fines are often made during special dinosaur bone hunting trips and expeditions
by these people to far away regions already inhabited and explored.
This seems highly implausible.
More believable is the case of the discovery of the first original Dead Sea
Scrolls in 1947 which were unintentionally discovered by a child and which were
all published by 1955
Oh,
okay.
So it's perfectly fine to accidentally find ancient scrolls or silver dinero AI
from the Roman period or a never before known pyramid and South America.
Oh no,
that's cool.
You know why?
Because humans fucking made those.
But it's completely out of the norm for some kid,
some nine year old kid to be walking around Montana and find a mummified
Hadrosaur because I don't know why I made that distinction.
That's it were weird comparison.
There's,
yeah,
it's more plausible the find the Dead Sea Scrolls in Qumran than it is to find a
megalodon tooth bullshit.
Bakersfield's yeah,
that doesn't make any sense.
No,
no.
It doesn't make any sense.
He's,
he's anthropomorphise sizing this and he's using a very,
an absolutely invalid invalid argument and a logical fallacies trying.
He's trying to,
its absolute false equivocation.
He's trying to go,
oh,
well,
you know,
you can't find this stuff because it's super,
super old,
but you can find this stuff because it's younger and it's humans and you know,
people live there.
So we'd expect stuff there.
Well guess what,
asshole?
There's 65 million years of difference between humans deciding to write shit
down and go,
hey,
uh,
there's a day and a night.
That means something's ruling the day in the night.
God's religion and industry and all that,
and dinosaurs eating shit 65 million years.
You,
we were tree shrews and moles.
We didn't,
we weren't building shit.
We weren't writing stuff down.
Such a false fucking argument.
God,
this guy said,
check.
So some cases of a discovery of dinosaur bones by a disinterested person.
It was suggested to them by some professional in the field [inaudible] in a
certain area.
It wasn't also very interesting to note our special areas set aside and
designated as dinosaur parks because we found a judging short.
Hector's are required to first obtain a dinosaur hunting license,
whatever destination these establishment finance national's hard paleontologists
set,
it seemed,
they found incredible numbers of fossils and tiny areas.
In one of the largest dinosaur excavation sites called the Ruth Mason Corey,
over 2000 fossils were allegedly discovered.
Stop saying,
fuck legend skeleton assembled from these bones are currently on display in over
60 museums worldwide because dino head of paleontology at Laplata museum is
amazingly responsible for 6,000 fossil species supposedly discovered throughout
his career all in Argentina or oh really?
Really?
Hey,
guess what Eric?
I ran a lab that we had three and a half million specimens from the ice age that
goes back 90,000 years.
So the libray a tarpits,
the largest ice age mammal collection on the fucking planet and this stuff isn't
mineralized.
It's actually subsumed with asphalt keeping the,
uh,
all of the calcium and everything intact.
These are actual bones.
When we find a saber tooth cat tooth,
it's the physical tooth of the animal.
Ooh.
Which is kind of freaky to think about but,
but,
but seeing that it's like,
yeah,
we find a lot of shit in places.
The river of death and Alberta d when they're digging the pipeline,
um,
I dunno.
Mammoth hot springs.
There are things called death traps and Predator traps in sinkholes and natural
trap caves and I don't know,
entire sand dunes falling on things while they're fighting the dueling
dinosaurs.
It's a air tops versus a velociraptor that was found in Mongolia because of
fucking sand.
Dune fell on them while they were tussling around cause the v Raptor wanted to
eat the thing it that,
that,
that's a rad specimen by the way.
You know what's interesting about this guy is that he knows so much is that his,
his,
his knowledge of the history of paleontology and of researching dinosaur bones,
he knows so much I call bullshit on that.
What I'm thinking is that he's reading from a script that he cobbled together on
fucking Wikipedia.
I challenge him to go toe to toe with somebody in the business.
I don't know,
like me and go,
okay,
start throwing date.
Start throwing specimens.
I will fucking own you be,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean he's,
he's obviously,
he knows all these people.
He knows about the bone war as he knows well,
who's in charge of all these different simple Google search of largest dinosaur
thing found.
Okay,
I'm going to write these three things down on this Manila in Manila.
Fucking,
I understand that.
I'm not saying that it's,
it's impressive and that it's conclusive evidence.
I'm saying it's,
it's impressive that this guy has done this much research but yet still has this
ridiculous idea and he's used to this.
Yeah.
He's using all this data that's actually factual about how many different people
found how many different things and he's decided that this is proof and all
information allegedly in front of it.
Yeah.
It's like,
no,
sorry.
Over 6,000 specimens were found there.
Fucking go with it.
Hunter.
Earl Douglas sent 350 tons of excavated dinosaur bones to the Carnegie Museum of
Natural History.
Throughout his career,
all coming from the Dinosaur National Monument in Utah.
Why do you think it's called the dinosaur national monument now,
Dr. Lewis Chackbay and Dr Lowell,
a key off bay,
actually thousands of dinosaur eggs at a site of only a few hundred square yard.
It was called the tiniest giant exhibition.
How such fines have huge quantities of fossils in one area by just a few highly
invested individuals.
It goes against the laws of natural probability to the likelihood of forgeries
or concentrated planting efforts wrong.
If you find a fossil planting efforts,
the plant,
what were the things that they planted?
They,
there's dinosaur bones that they planted,
that's the dinosaur bones made out of like residency.
So that is actually an argument with these jackasses.
It's like,
okay,
so big Paleo.
The big paleontologist,
people like me being Paleo,
Paleo,
big Pharma,
and big they,
and you know all that podcast,
Jamie.
We're big podcasts where an industry,
so they say they not in the black man,
you know,
black helicopter day,
but they as in the detractors state that paleontologists like me,
we'll create a fossil,
whether it's like a cast or we'll just make one up and on these expeditions we
go out and we actually bury it and uncover it and make the news and all that.
Well,
if that was true,
Eric,
why is it that when we find something say in,
I dunno,
okay.
It's not usually written about until say 2012 and that's just a symbol,
a single note in the Journal of Vertebrate Paleontology,
which I guarantee you've never read or it's done as a poster at the Society of
Vertebrate Paleontology,
which I will absolutely guarantee you've never been to.
Yeah.
And then the fossils still in prep at that point,
we haven't done all the research on it.
It's still undiscovered fossil found.
If we are going out and investing all of this money in order to make these fakes
and bury them and pay all of these people to shut them up and huge excavations
like that,
we would kind of want to recoup that money as fast as possible and immediately
dump it to the news and get paid for spokesman ships and all of that,
but we don't.
We suffer natural history.
Museums are some of the lowest donated two institutions on the planet.
Art Museums are generally number one.
There are people that get laid off all the time from museums,
museums close.
If we were making all this money and making all this fame,
why are there paleontologists out of a job?
Why do I know a dozen monitors that don't have work right now?
Why are their museums that have problem actually getting a budget to get an
excavation going that they have to use private donors,
that they have to use their board of directors,
that they have to go from a county museum to a foundation,
nonprofit non profit.
This is such a line of fucking bullshit that,
I mean that that pisses me off because his simple statements are looping in
thousands and tens of thousands of employees and museums and all of that
worldwide.
This would be one of the largest conspiracies ever other than,
I dunno.
Moon hoax is a NASA earth flat earth and shit other he does.
Yeah.
That is the other one.
Keep gone.
Ah,
let's get them one on one.
Dinosaur bones sell for a lot of money at auctions.
It is a profitable business.
There is pressure for academics to publish papers.
Museums are in the business of producing displays that are popular and
appealing.
What the nonprofit uselessness media need to produce material to sell to stay in
business.
The mainstream media loves to hype alleged dinosaur fines much just to be gained
by converting a bland non dinosaur discovery of a bone of modern origin into an
impressive dinosaur.
Find and letting artists interpretations and imaginations take the spotlight.
Okay.
Rather than the basic boring real find.
Um,
if,
if that's true,
then why do dinosaurs become passe?
Why does somebody like who has been on,
I don't know,
13,
14 different television shows talking about paleontology,
geology and all that.
I have pitched dinosaur,
like live dig stuff to BBC and all of that.
I'm consulting on a couple projects right now,
unfortunately,
can't name them,
but uh,
dinosaurs become passe very,
very quickly because people are like,
oh,
cool.
New dinosaurs found.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
Or Oh well brontosauruses back.
Yeah,
whatever.
But the mainstream media as he said,
is just like,
they love a dinosaur story,
but that's bullshit.
That's absolute bullshit.
When was the women's the last like dinosaur document?
Yeah,
there was um,
uh,
what was it called?
Autopsy of a t rex with,
uh,
my friend Tori and uh,
that,
that okay.
That was a speculative science show.
It was like,
what happens if we found a t rex and cut it open and do an autopsy?
That was a hit and then paleontology TV died again two years ago.
I had a,
to our national geographic documentary about digging up wooly mammoths in that
it aired a night.
There was a little bit of press fucking done.
The production company that did the,
the,
the thing with nat geo is out of business now,
just done.
It's like,
really?
We're,
we're pressured and to get this money then why aren't we making fucking more?
Why Eric,
am I a bartender in addition to a paleontologist in addition to somebody that's
on TV,
if I making all this big Pharma or sorry,
big Paleo fucking money.
If I'm such a shill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that why I'm a month behind on my car payment right now?
Is that why I'm trying to scrape together rent?
Fuck.
You can aggressive.
Oh,
I'm very aggressive.
Fuck these guys.
Fame and attention.
There's the bandwagon effect and crowd behavior and then their entity.
Wait,
but wait,
wait,
wait.
The bandwagon effect and the crowd behavior like flat earth bullshit.
Okay.
We're only seven minutes and 53 seconds into a 29 minute video.
Fuck all.
We don't have to keep going.
I don't want you to get too mad.
I think you kind of made your point.
You can pull the plug in anytime you want,
but now it's like one of those Twitter arguments.
Man.
Now I'm getting invested,
fucking troll me all the time because we follow each other,
we DM each other and all of a sudden in my thing,
it's like I have you on note cause we're both verified,
it pops up and it's just like Joe Rogan is tweeting about flat earth.
I'm like fuck.
And then just go for it.
It's like you're,
I mean like,
you know the podcast and like flight commentary and UFC stuff and like with
your,
with like triggered coming out and all that.
That's one thing when you rile up the cranks,
man,
you're just like,
you're at the same level.
Just actually you have,
how many followers do you have?
Like 2 million,
right?
Does it like on Twitter?
Uh,
Tdt a take a Darwin.
I like 10,
maybe 15,000.
I get the same level of riled from both of you.
Fuck man.
So we need to fly him out and have him on the show.
This guy,
this?
No,
no,
Eric.
No,
no,
no.
Take that Darwin.
Yeah,
no,
he,
he'd be a fun,
he would be Rad.
Yeah,
you would be fun.
Fuck Eric Dubay.
If he's ever on the show,
I want to be outside waiting with a fucking baseball bat.
Oh,
how do you want to be violent with him?
Almost almost that you want to talk to him.
Would you have to meet?
I think you could gain a lot from sitting down with a guy like this and just
sort of picking them apart because you would realize what he was wrong about and
instead of him being able to just spout off on a youtube video who'd would be
checked at every step of the way whenever he said something incorrect.
Yes,
but the problem is the only reason why I would do that,
he will never change his mind.
Well,
he's probably crazy.
Duh.
He's absolutely crazy.
But think about it right now.
You have 4 million subscribers that now know this video exists,
that no Eric debased name,
that know that paleontologist w can get riled up by this guy.
They're now going to go look,
if any one of your listeners is on the fence about dinosaurs,
why would you be?
But you could have some,
those are the people that I would have to try and convince.
I will never convince him.
I will mock the living shit out of him until he wants to put himself into a
chipper shredder.
But I will never convince him.
It's the,
and that's,
that's the thing.
So all you Sai Khan people out there,
we don't do it to try and convince the big mouth pieces for these movements were
trying to go for the people that aren't quite sure if we embarrass the living
fuck out of these people,
those people would go,
wow,
those guys are idiots.
Why did I even consider that the world is flat,
or the dinosaurs didn't exist,
or creationism exists,
or chem trails or Nibiru fucking rogue planets and shit like that.
Okay.